so this is a choice based game so you'll
be absolutely may I assume it's a game
you can play through multiple times make
different choices I see how this is so
branches out each time absolutely
there's there's there's hours of
different variations so this just to set
this up this scene the Apes are coming
down into the into the valley they're
starving there they're on the point of
starvation and they come across a human
encampment and it basically the father
of the Clapp the clan leader is saying
no don't confront the human beings it'll
only bring about our destruction and and
these three brothers are going down and
they will have their different opinions
and as I say you're playing as Brinn and
all this is motion capture this is all
purely performance captured yeah I mean
and and one was shot in The Imaginarium
studios so now so obviously you you can
do then choose you know do you agree
with Toller who's more of an aggressor
he wants to go down and and then or you
can choose not to get involved well
let's say let's say you were right
taller so we're going to follow two more
exciting exactly let's do that and have
you found that performance capture has
evolved over the years obviously you
were heavily involved with things like
Lord of the Rings back in the day and it
is really kind of exploded since then
and it's now very prevalent in video
games as well what's what's it like now
working and seeing performance capture
appearing in games like this I must be
it's it's thrilling because it really
does prove that performance capture sits
right in the middle of you know
transmedia storytelling and can be used
as I say in so many different platforms
now and and it's it's acted performances
which have great levels of okay so so we
must take not take them so you can
either choose to come back or we this
will be easy let's say this will be Z
let's be let's be more aggressive here
and did you direct the performance
capture for this game no no no I was the
we're the producer so The Imaginarium
Studios The Imaginarium rather produced
it and The Imaginarium Studios carried
out the performance capture and the
imagine RTR they publishers and the
director came along right so will will
bully will bully Juno and tell them to
shut up because we want to get down
there it's quite telling that you call
it a performance capture as well not
just motion capture because I guess the
whole face is being exact or on than
just the body as well exactly
so let's reassure them Juno trust me
come on let's get down there
it's also nice to see a game within the
Planet of the Apes franchise there isn't
massively action-based it is is very
story based it's all about the decisions
and and the structure behind those
decisions as well and you can play you
can play as I say it's a multiplayer
game which opens up hugely using playlng
and Medea is to move quickly and you can
override people's decisions so it
becomes about right so it becomes about
ultimately when you're playing and it
really is a multiplayer game you know
you you you you can if you override you
can only overwrite once and then you
have to follow the other other players
so you've got to be careful when you
want to use that
let's deal with the humans let's go you
know in a very aggressive we're going
straight for him but the quite I mean
the thing is it is about survival
ultimately this game and and there is
jeopardy in there for all for all the
characters and is there like a game over
state for instance can you make the
wrong decision and then have your
characters die or will that will the
story accommodate those kind of
decisions it's the story of Commodore
this story does accommodate them okay
we're going in I mean it's it is a very
moody kind of you know in immersive game
which kind of does require acquire
environment that's going to support that
so this is the perhaps the best one for
for this but it really is it's about
tension building as well so it really
does get quite tense as you're going
through and as I say you can play you
can actually play this completely from
the perspective of human beings so you
could be playing as the humans in this
absolutely right
and when you've got four players playing
together you said you said you could
override decisions do you all have to
agree on a certain course of action
before the story can move forward is um
sorry hold on say hold X there we go oh
shoot
Wow
do we want to stop now we don't you
don't want to stop so I like this
somehow choosing to do nothing can be a
decision in itself well okay I mean come
back to your point you know you can't so
it encourages debate and yes it
encourages you know you can they can get
quite heated and instances like that
you've got a very short time limit in
which I'm gonna put a lot of pressure
but see ya puts pressure on I mean
though it's different as a single play
but
okay so let's accuse Tala let's see
what's going on here
and so if you'd have played this
cautiously could there be a situation
where there's no kind of conflict here
at all there is I mean it'll it'll creep
back in it look and so you're always
you're always under pressure
it'll just take you down a different
route yeah yeah but it but there yeah I
mean you you the Jeopardy comes with
with the disagreement within the grill
so yeah there we go so if we reach the
end of our demo now or so this is going
into the human camp now okay
and is only now
[Music]
this burden of responsibility
[Music]
for my home for those who live here
[Music]
for my family
[Music]
these are dangerous times
[Music]
but these are my decisions to make and
whatever path I take family is all
family is
you
[Music]
you